in this video we're going to talk about
how to find out where a point is located
in which quadrant given some
restrictions we're going to go through
six examples see if you can do these on
your own and we'll go through them
together so the first one it says X is
equal to 3 but the Y value is less than
0 so when we think of the x and y
coordinates right when the Y value is
less than 0 that means it's going to be
below the x axis that means we have to
be in the third or fourth quadrant and X
is equal to 3 and that means we're going
3 to the right but Y is less than 0
meaning negative so that's going to put
us right here in the fourth quadrant so
I'm just going to use the Roman numeral
IV for for remember the quadrants go in
this counterclockwise fashion 1 2 3 4
let's look at another example see if you
can do this one here it just tells us
that Y has to be greater than 3 so we
can think about okay if we were to go 1
2 3 so Y is 3 like actually greater than
3 meaning above this right but it
doesn't tell us what the x value could
be it could be negative meaning we're
going to the left actually be positive
mean you were going to the right all we
know is that we're above 3 so that means
we could be in either quadrant 1 or 2 so
we've actually got the two quadrants as
our answer there well so get number 3 X
is less than negative 1 so remember X
controls left and right the horizontal
direction so if X is less than negative
1 that means to the left of negative 1
there's no restrictions put on the y
coordinate so that means we could either
be going positive up or negative down so
that's gonna put us in the second or
third quadrant so again we get two
answers for that one for number four we
have negative 2 X is greater than 0 and
Y is less than 0
well let's solve this one here for X if
we divide both sides by negative 2 what
happens to that inequality sign well
remember when you divide by a negative
the inequality sign changes direction 0
divided by negative 2 is still going to
be 0 so X has to be less than 0 so it
means we're going to be to the left of
the y-axis and Y is less than 0 so Y is
less than sir that's negative or going
to be below the
x-axis that's gonna put us in the third
quadrant let's look at another one let's
say number five here this one's a bit
more challenging so x squared times y is
less than zero
now this one's kind of interesting
because when you have a negative value
squared a negative times a negative is a
positive if you have a positive value
squared a positive times a positive is
also positive right so no matter what
this is gonna be positive so I'm just
going to put a plus there for positive Y
though here could be positive or
negative if it's negative a negative
times a positive is a negative and
that's less than zero if Y is positive a
positive times a positive is positive
that's not less than zero so that means
that X could be anything positive or
negative Y has to be less than zero
meaning negative so positive times a
negative a give us a negative so let's
see Y is less than zero that's going to
be here and X can we say it can be
negative or positive so that's going to
be the third or fourth quadrant and then
the last one see if you can do this one
three times x times y is greater than
zero let's just go ahead and divide by
three to get the variables by themselves
here so x times y is greater than zero
well remember greater than zero just
means positive right so we could have a
X is positive and Y is positive a
positive times a positive
that'll be positive greater than zero or
x and y can both be negative because a
negative times a negative is positive
and that's greater than zero so where
does that occur well you can see a
positive times a positive that's
positive a negative times a negative
that's positive so it looks like it's
going to be in quadrants one and three
and you've got it if you enjoyed this
video and you want to see more math
tutoring videos check out my Mario's
math tutoring youtube channel where I've
got hundreds of videos like these from
pre-algebra all the way up through
precalculus even some calculus videos
I'll see over in those other videos